ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all so much
for making it out.
My name is Artur Oliveira.
I'm on the authors
at Google team.
And it is my pleasure to
introduce your speaker today.
A lot of you might
be wondering what
does serving great
guacamole have
to do with eradicating poverty?
And the thing is, I don't know.
That's why we have
Josh Ruxin here,
who is here today with us to
talk about his brand new book
"A Thousand Hills
Through Heaven,
Love, Hope, and a
Restaurant in Rwanda."
Now, the "New York
Times" called it an
observing and
affecting narrative.
And the book has been receiving
a lot of praise recently,
so this really is a treat.
Josh is on faculty at
Columbia University,
and he's been living
in Rwanda since 2005.
So without further ado, if we
could please welcome up Josh.
JOSH RUXIN: Thank you, Artur.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hi, everybody.
So, this whole story actually
starts about 30 years ago.
I was a high school
student at the height
of the Ethiopian famine.
I didn't really
know much about it.
But there was a really
cute upper class woman
who I saw go into some
meeting after school.
And I thought, huh, I
wonder where she's going,
so I followed her in
and started to learn
about this incredible
catastrophe that was costing
of course millions
of lives in Ethiopia.
This was back 1984, 1985.
And that was actually the very
beginning of my interest in it
all.
A couple years later, it
led to a trip to Ethiopia.
I was just a teenager.
I'd never been outside
of the country before,
and ended up taking a little
plane to the middle of nowhere
in northern Ethiopia, get out
of the plane on a grassy field.
And everybody
dropped their plows
and came over to look
at this white teenager
from Connecticut.
And a teacher came over
and started to translate
and asked all the kids
who were gathered around,
how do you think this kid and
the other students got here?
And one kid raised his
hand and says, by mule?
And then another kid points at
me and says, come, in Amharic.
And so I end up walking with
these kids about a mile up
to this mud-walled classroom.
And there's a poster,
which has got pictures
of this club from high school
from three years earlier
that we had sent with an
aid worker years before.
And that for me was that aha
moment that I'm sure all of you
have had in one way or
another about how very, very
small this planet is,
how you're only ever
24 hours away from the
poorest places, the most
desperate places.
And I decided then,
hey, I want to make
some sort of contribution.
I want to figure out how
to make a difference.
And the next 30
years have been spent
trying to figure out
how the heck to do that,
because it's not as easy as
just having your heart into it.
So, about eight years ago, now
nine years ago, my wife and I
were just about to be married.
And we were given a very
unusual sendoff gift.
A very wealthy donor and
fundraiser said to us, hey,
I've seen a really
interesting poverty reduction
program in Kenya and
some other places,
but it's not happening in
Rwanda, and it should be.
So why don't you, Josh, and
with your new wife Alissa,
head to Rwanda and get it going.
At that time, my wife had
a public health degree
from Harvard.
She was sick and tired of taking
the subway down to Wall Street,
where she was running a
executive public health
program at Goldman Sachs.
And she said, sure, let's go.
We'll go for a year or two.
And we never came back.
We got to Rwanda just 10
years after the genocide.
And I'm sure when most of
you think about Rwanda,
that is what you think
about, the "Hotel
Rwanda," the senseless
horrible slaughter of over
a million people in a
hundred days back in 1994.
But we actually
arrived in a country
that, while it certainly bore
the scars of the genocide,
was clean, secure,
beautiful, with wonderful,
welcoming people that was
very much on the move.
It was actually even
then growing at rates
that would make this
administration very jealous,
nearly double-digit economic
growth rates every year.
So I arrived to start working
at the Millennium Village
site, which is just down
south of Kigali in a place
called Mayange.
And it was not booming.
It actually was suffering
from a horrible famine.
The health center as
I found it back then,
this was actually the
ambulance at the health center.
Most days it was shut.
The doors were just not open.
And I asked, how
do you get a nurse?
And they said, well,
you can go find her
if you've got money
to go find her.
And then compounding everything,
the land had no topsoil.
All the topsoil had
rolled down the hills
because of deforestation.
And people were
literally starving
because they couldn't
produce enough food to eat.
So with my colleagues, we
started at the very beginning,
which was, as long as people
are dying from starvation,
no one's really going to
want to listen to a word
that we have to say.
So we started working on
progressive terracing and line
planting.
And pretty soon,
those very hills--
this is a picture taken
from the same exact angle--
started to green up and
started to produce food.
And that was actually
the very first harvest.
That ended up
changing everything,
because lots of our thinking
around building community
grew out of the
notion that you need
to have an integrated
set of interventions
in order to reduce
poverty ultimately.
And I'll never
forget, one day, one
of the early adopters in the
community-- who this might well
have been her field.
I can't remember.
Her name's Jacqueline-- she
came up to me, and she said,
you know, Josh, I'm
really angry with you,
because for years I was
the funeral director here.
And we had deaths all the time.
And I actually made
a decent living
directing those funerals.
But you've put me
out of business.
No one dies here anymore.
And that was the moment that
the whole community really
started to take over its
development interventions,
completely own it.
And today, we've basically
scaled down that project.
And if it's any sign
of the reduction
if not virtual
elimination of poverty,
the real estate prices
have gone up fivefold
since the bottom in 2005 when
people were literally just
leaving because there was
no reason to be in Mayange.
Oh, that's Jacqueline,
by the way.
So meanwhile, my
wife was in Kigali,
and she was working with
the orphans of the genocide.
And she was working on a
program called Generation Rwanda
helping some of
these kids get access
to scholarships for university.
But the vast majority didn't
have access to scholarships.
There weren't enough
donors to pay for them.
And Alissa had a huge insight,
which was these kids need jobs.
And with jobs,
they're going to be
able to put themselves
through university.
I said, great, honey.
What do you propose?
She said, well, how about
we just open a cafe?
There's no good place to get
a cup of coffee around here.
So, being a supportive husband,
I said, that sounds great.
I had this vision
of plastic chairs,
and plastic tables, and maybe
a really nice espresso maker.
And then some investors
put millions of dollars
behind a Starbucks-style
cafe in Kigali.
And she said, OK,
second thought,
let's do something different.
Let's build the best gourmet
restaurant in East Africa.
So this is actually
the building site.
Alissa found this land.
It's literally just two blocks
away from the famed hotel
Rwanda, the Hotel
des Mille Collines.
And this is construction
back in 2007
when my wife was pregnant
with our first child.
And this is the construction
of the magnificent deck
overlooking all of Kigali.
And eventually Heaven emerged.
That's what it looks like
today just before service.
Most nights we have a lot more
customers than in that picture.
And it's been an incredibly
rewarding but on a daily basis
hugely challenging endeavor.
From the very beginning, most of
our servers, most of our chefs,
most everyone who
works at Heaven
had never had a job
before and had never
even set foot in a restaurant.
So the training element of
this hospitality business
has not gone away.
In fact, we have rotating
chefs and rotating
front-of-house managers.
So if anyone has any friends out
there, every six months or so,
people cycle through, usually
from the States and Europe,
to really invest in
the team at Heaven.
I can send you the
job description
if you're interested.
So what does, I mean
as Artur set this up,
what does serving
up great guacamole
or great filet mignon have
to do with poverty reduction?
That was something
that I started
to figure out very early
on in the enterprise.
One of our first cleaners
was a woman named Solange.
Solange, I don't even
think I knew her name back
in 2008 when we opened up.
And one day Alissa found
Solange in the kitchen,
like around 11:00 or
so, preparing food.
But she was the cleaner.
And Alissa came
home, and she said,
you won't believe who was
in the kitchen cooking.
I said, who?
She said the cleaner was.
This is ridiculous.
We've got to sit
down with the staff.
down with the chefs.
Why are they pawning off
the work onto Solange?
So that night, we sat down with
the whole kitchen staff just
before service.
And I said, what
are you all doing?
Why was Solange in here cooking?
And they replied, well, she
was just making staff meal.
I said, yeah, but
that's your job.
They said, yeah, but
she's the best cook.
So Solange today is actually
the sous chef at Heaven.
She's worked under
Michelin-star chefs.
She makes the best squash
risotto you've ever tasted.
She can knock out without
even planning for it--
for some reason, when
people come into Heaven,
they don't make reservations.
So people will think
nothing of walking
into this restaurant in
Central Africa with 30 people
and expecting world-class
service and world-class food.
And Solange is actually able
to knock those meals right out
of the kitchen with no problem.
That's Heaven by
night out on the deck.
That's Solange.
Solange, by the way, is
the very first member
of her entire family
to go to university.
There's about a dozen
kids and family at home
who are completely
supported by her income.
She pays for their health care.
She pays for their education.
And yet Solange doesn't receive
a charitable contribution.
She doesn't receive a
501(c)(3) annual check.
She's working for pay.
And that lesson about
financial sustainability
really changed my
outlook about how
to think about what I've been
doing in the public health
sector.
So in public health, I've
got this organization
called Health Builders.
You can check it out,
globalhealthbuilders.org.
And we do two things.
We actually take lessons
from Heaven in accounting,
and human resources,
and in management.
We go into health centers.
We help them improve these
public health centers
to the point where they
are cash flow positive.
They're real
functional businesses.
And then we do
something landmark.
We actually let them go.
Because that's one of the keys
to doing development right
is knowing when
you've done your job
and when everyone can
take over and manage
the future of the health
center or the restaurant.
Though we're not
there yet with Heaven.
And this is an example
of that thinking
around financial
sustainability put to use.
This is a health center right
up by the mountain gorillas up
in the northern
part of the country.
It was co-financed by a
donor, a very generous donor,
and by local funds.
So we put together a public
contract and built it.
And then we trained the staff
up and opened the doors.
There's no plaque there
that says Health Builders.
It is a government of
Rwanda health facility,
and it runs on its own.
So that's really
the way that I see
the future of
development happening
is that in countries
like Rwanda, where
the government cares
about the public's health
and really cares about real
development and poverty
eradication, it's going to
be between the public sector
and the private sector.
The very first night
that Heaven opened,
my country director
for the health work
is a guy named [INAUDIBLE]
Carabucci, huge guy,
really tall.
He says he's 6 foot 6.
I think he's over 7 feet.
And he walks in, looks out
over 150 customers in Heaven,
grabs my wife, and says,
we don't need aid anymore.
We don't need donor
assistance anymore in Rwanda.
What we need is a
thousand Heavens.
We actually need
lots of businesses
like this that are investing
in management training, that
are generating salaries.
That's what's going to
change this country.
That's what's going
to change the world.
And actually that
was the working title
for a while for the book.
So, I know that a lot of
people often ask me, well,
how do I have impact?
I want to become a doctor.
I want to become a nurse.
Or I want to go to
public health school
because I want to
make a difference.
And my top-level
advice on that front
is, you don't have to do those
things in order to have impact.
And for that matter, you
don't have to become a martyr,
sacrifice yourself, in
order to have huge impact.
I think that's a little bit
of the conventional wisdom
is you've got to
give everything up
in order to reduce poverty
and have social impact.
And our experience has
been much different.
We have a good life.
We've got three kids.
We have high stress, high
anxiety, just like everybody
does with their jobs.
But we feel really
lucky to live in Rwanda
and to have the opportunity
to make a contribution
in a way that is dignifying
and in a way that
is led by the Rwandan
people and by our friends.
So with that I wanted to
open it up to all of you
and have a little bit of a
discussion about this very
large restaurant.
We can seat up to 200.
In fact, there were 200 people
in last night, called Heaven.
AUDIENCE: So, it's a high-end
restaurant, and it's serving,
I'm assuming, wealthier people.
Are the people that mostly
come in native Rwandans
or more tourists?
JOSH RUXIN: It's a split.
So, about a third
of our clientele
are tourists who have come to
see the gorillas in the mist.
And about a third are expats.
There's over 3,000
Americans, for example,
who live in Kigali.
And about a third are Rwandans,
mainly higher class Rwandans.
But if it's Mother's
Day, if it's a birthday,
if it's Christmas Eve or New
Year's, it is a total mix,
and it's almost all Rwandese.
Rwandans actually-- this has
been a real challenge for us--
don't have a culture of food.
And eating was
actually something
done at home, done
behind closed doors.
Maybe that grew out of
the scarcity of food
over generations.
And so you will find Rwandese
who drive in Porsche Cayennes,
but they insist
on eating at home.
So it's been a challenge for
us to really teach and educate
the market about great food
and what that tastes like.
AUDIENCE: And then,
just a quick follow-up,
I guess what I was
wondering is did you
get any backlash in terms of
having people lift themselves
out of poverty but also with
this kind of contrasting
high-end restaurant,
so the idea of people
taking jobs to
lift themselves out
of poverty by serving people
that are wealthier than them?
JOSH RUXIN: No.
AUDIENCE: I mean just in
terms of a class issue.
JOSH RUXIN: No, I
don't think over
the years we've ever
seen that class issue.
AUDIENCE: So the focus is just
really positive on the job
creation and everything
that's going on?
JOSH RUXIN: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
JOSH RUXIN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have two question.
The first one, you mentioned
that you left to Rwanda
and never came back.
So the first question
is, what happened
with the rest of your family,
extended family, friends?
Were they supportive?
JOSH RUXIN: Oh, the
family back here--
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
JOSH RUXIN: Oh yeah, I
was just about to say,
that whole family's
in Kigali right now.
AUDIENCE: No, exactly,
that's the first one.
And the second one is that
because of those connection,
maybe, did they help
either via donation
or some of your friends decided
to go there and help you?
Or did they just
say, hey, good luck.
We wish you the best.
JOSH RUXIN: Well, we are
not independently wealthy
and when we were
building Heaven ran
into cost overruns,
cost overruns.
We had actually taken
out a second mortgage
on our apartment back in New
York City, which of course we
had had every
intention to return to.
And then we burned through
that second mortgage
and then contacted
our immediate family
and asked them to help us
out and write some checks.
And then we burned
through all that.
And we were feeling very
sheepish before even opening
the doors and turned
to friends and had
them write checks,
not as donations.
And over the course of
the first two years,
we actually paid off all
the friends and family,
and then just last year paid
off the rest of the debt.
So that's the debt
situation, which isn't really
what your question
was referring to.
In terms of family
and their reaction,
they come and they visit.
They always expected
that we would come back.
But here's something
interesting,
which is, when I started
working in development
back when I graduated
from university,
I remember this
is the early '90s,
and I was living in Bolivia.
And I would receive a letter
and read the letter every day
for a month and a half
until I got another letter.
And my kids on a
weekly basis get
to use Skype video with
their grandparents.
I get to see my
friends all the time.
It is completely transformed
what that experience is.
Literally distance
has been destroyed.
And it's so much easier than
it ever was before to do it.
Of course, when I tell
my wife that who's
about to board 32
hours of transport
with the three kids this
Friday evening, she says,
no, it's not any easier.
Can't we just go on holiday
break in the neighborhood?
But outside of
that, the families
have been incredibly supportive.
And they love Rwanda.
I mean, everyone has
fallen in love with Rwanda.
It really is this
incredible jewel.
And I think they all see
our hope, and our dream,
and our imagination,
which is, let's not
leave all the great things
in Rwanda in Rwanda.
Let's expand it.
Let's expand the health
work to other countries.
Let's expand Heaven
to other places.
Actually Alissa opened up a
little boutique guest house
just last year.
It's been one of the best
parts of the whole business,
and she wants to expand
it to create more jobs
and hospitality to really get
a feel for the whole spectrum
of what international
consumers are looking for.
AUDIENCE: So you hear a
lot in Uganda and Nigeria
about sort of the problem
with brain drain and people
having aspirations to leave
the country for education
and maybe having
intentions to come back.
I know Rwanda's a
little different
with the recent history,
but how is the education
infrastructure?
Do a lot of people want to
leave Rwanda for education?
JOSH RUXIN: They certainly do.
But first off, Rwanda is
a tale of exceptionalism
because the genocide
didn't just happen in 1994.
You've got to go back to
1959 to see its roots.
And from 1959 to 1994, you
had hundreds of thousands
of people who left the country.
Some lived in refugee camps
in Uganda and elsewhere.
But some made their way to the
States, to the UK, to Belgium.
They got educated, and as
soon as the war was over
and the genocide was over,
they started coming back in.
And so you literally
had this case
of the reverse of brain drain.
You had incredibly
skilled people
who were exposed to
the outside world.
Bear in mind, you
saw the map before.
Rwanda is landlocked.
There's no poor.
It was never on a spice route.
And so critically,
that is in part
where the prosperity
and the future of Rwanda
has been pinned, all these
people who actually came back
with real knowledge
about what's going
on in the outside world, what's
happening in technology, what's
happening in business.
So today what
happens, certainly, I
know lots of students who have
gone abroad and stayed abroad.
But I also know a whole lot who
have gone abroad and come back
for jobs in tech
and jobs in banking.
I wish they would come
back for jobs at Heaven,
because that level of
management is really needed.
It's needed at Heaven.
It's needed in
the health sector.
It's needed in all those areas.
And it is building.
But Rwanda is essentially
a new country, so reborn
just 19 years ago.
The 20th anniversary is
coming up of the genocide.
And I think a lot of
people with Mandela's death
are starting to think
about that and remember,
oh yeah, when Nelson Mandela
was elected president-- that
was in April 1994--
all eyes were on that
while the genocide was
unfolding in Rwanda.
And I think that
it's unfortunate
that we look to Africa now, and
we think about Mandela's legacy
and overlook the fact
that one of the best
stories of leadership, and
growth, and prosperity,
and stability on
the entire continent
and in the entire world is
up to the north in the place
that I call home.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I just want to
say I was in Rwanda in 2008,
and I went to your restaurant.
JOSH RUXIN: Thank you
for being a patron.
AUDIENCE: And it was one of
the most memorable experiences
I had in Africa.
And I also wondered if you
had any experience starting
restaurants in the US and if
you ran into any reluctance
from the local people about an
American starting a business.
Because when I was there,
I was under the impression
it was an African-owned
restaurant.
Because we were told
it was run by orphans.
And it didn't have the
feeling of an American
or a foreign-owned business.
JOSH RUXIN: That's good to hear.
I guess I wasn't
working that night.
So, I suppose if we had had
any restaurant experience,
we might not have been so
naive as to have gotten
into this business
in the first place.
It's the world's
hardest business.
And Alissa outside of a
short stint as a barista
had no experienced in
any related industry.
I actually was
always the one who
wore the apron in
the relationship.
She's cooked, in the
course of our marriage
and our relationship,
exactly one meal for me.
And that was very early on.
I've done all the
cooking ever since.
And in the early
days, I actually
did a lot of the cooking
and a lot of the training
back in the kitchen.
I love food.
I love cooking.
I am not a chef.
I recognize my
shortcomings, and that's
why we started bringing
on international chefs
to think about the management.
And there's so much to
think about in terms
of inventory and planing.
And as Americans in Rwanda
starting up a business
and starting up a
restaurant, we were embraced.
I mean, it took no
more than 48 hours
to incorporate the business.
Anyone, any one of you
can come to Rwanda.
If you've got a
business idea, you
can literally go to the
Rwanda Development Board,
incorporate your
business, and get moving.
It is effortless there.
So they really are
welcoming private investment
and bringing entrepreneurial
skills and management
to the country.
AUDIENCE: So you said
you weren't there yet
in terms of handing off
Heaven to be owned maybe
by the people that work there.
Are there plans to do that?
What's the timeline?
What does that look like?
JOSH RUXIN: Well, I think we're
in an interesting position
right now.
The restaurant and the
inn are doing well.
But it still does take an
enormous amount of effort
from my wife, and on a really
busy night from both of us.
It's sort of still all
hands on deck because
of the unpredictability
of the business.
And it's very hard to build that
management set in Heaven staff
and bring them up to
that management level.
We're constantly working on
that and aiming for that.
And I think one of
the solutions for it
is Heaven actually needs to
grow to be a little bit bigger
as a business in order to
have international trainers
constantly on board,
constantly on staff,
so that we can move
on and do other things
and not be as engaged in
day-to-day management.
That said, compared
to back in 2008,
when Alyssa and I would be
at the restaurant until 1:00
in the morning
every single night,
and then I went to my day job,
which was in public health.
Compared to those days,
we are very, very far
advanced and much, much
closer to the realization
of that sustainability.
But the restaurant business
is a little tricky.
It doesn't matter where
you are in the world.
You know when the
owner is not around.
That's just the
nature of the beast.
And I hope that we can
really get to that point.
At the same time, Heaven has
become this incredible platform
for Alissa in particular
to build out her ideas.
So last Saturday, she hosted
on that beautiful terrace
the very first farmers
market in Rwanda's history
and got all sorts of
organic growers and people
producing really
interesting products
to come in and do that.
There's theater that
happens that she brings in
and art exhibitions.
And so it's a lot more than just
dishing up food and dishing up
a great customer experience.
It's also about serving
as a real cultural venue
to show off all the great things
that are happening in Rwanda.
AUDIENCE: So I was actually
born and raised in Kigali,
and I'm half Rwandan.
And I went to your
restaurant in 2011.
It was really good.
And I want to thank you
for spreading the gospel.
But my question was, you
have mentioned many times
how exceptionally run Rwanda
was and how safe it is.
What are your thoughts
on aid for places
that aren't run like Rwanda?
JOSH RUXIN: So as you
will read in the book,
I have pretty
strong views on this
that when you think about
aid and the level of aid,
for example, of the US
government in Rwanda,
it's been well placed
and well positioned.
Rwanda is famous for having some
of the world's lowest levels
of corruption.
And I'm all for
that kind of aid.
Because when the
government in particular
cares about the public's health
and the public's development--
you haven't been
there since 2011?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH RUXIN: Wi-Fi is on the
public buses now in Kigali.
It's just extraordinary
the ambition of the place.
But I've worked in so
many other countries
where government
officials have asked me
for bribes, where I felt as
though the work of Health
Builders just could
not take off because
of the corruption of
the public sector.
And in a world where
realistically, we've
got finite resources,
sadly, for doing things
like public health,
I would much rather
see those funds channeled to
countries like Rwanda that
have a plan for sustainability,
that have a plan for not
accepting donor
aid in the future
in building out a tax base
to do it on their own.
And I get enraged
when I see countries
which have the resources, have
the means, have the wealth
and just aren't
doing it and yet are
receiving big chunks of aid.
As a humanitarian, I'm compelled
and feel enormous sympathy
for the poor.
But at the same time,
I feel as though we
need better systems
and better milestones
in order to get the
governments to take
this type of development on, and
internalize it, and build out
what has happened in Rwanda.
In my book, I refer
to five lessons.
And my lesson about what to
say to those countries that
are incredibly corrupt
that are looking for aid
relates to the middle finger.
AUDIENCE: So you
said in the beginning
there was no local cuisine
because people just
don't eat out.
What is your cuisine?
And what have you done
to maybe tease out
the locals to participate?
JOSH RUXIN: So we've done
a combination of things.
So the main local cuisine
when Rwandese go out
for a traditional meal, it might
be goat brochette, rice, beans,
relatively simple
food with piri piri,
really spicy sauce,
and also maybe
some matoke in a tomato sauce.
We have a very eccentric menu.
We have got probably our
signature dish, which
has been on the menu now since
we opened, is our filet mignon.
You want to talk about
green, pasture-fed cows,
I mean, you're not going to find
more sustainably raised cattle
than what you'll find in Rwanda.
It is a fabulous piece of beef.
And then we smother it in a
cassava chimichurri sauce.
So we take cassava
leaves, which are often
served as a local food in
the form of a sombe, which
is with palm oil.
And we do it with olive
oil, some garlic, and onion.
And then sometimes we'll
actually take the matoke.
We'll take cream.
We'll take green bananas,
and we'll mash them up
with some butter
instead of potatoes.
So it has these local
flavors, but it is clearly
an international dish.
And then I got to
confess, probably
our most popular
dessert over the years
has always been our
molten chocolate brownie
with our homemade ice cream.
Anyway, well, it is so great to
be here with all of you today.
And I want to welcome
you to Heaven.
Come on in.
You can have a mojito on me.
And come out to Rwanda, and
come have the experience
of seeing this country that
has so much to show the world.
Lots of people say,
oh, can I come on,
and can I volunteer for
two weeks or three weeks?
And I say, don't
think that you need
to come out as a
volunteer to have impact.
You can have impact by
coming out as a tourist,
spending money,
eating in Heaven,
eating in other restaurants,
giving good customer feedback,
and spreading the word.
Because that is a massive source
of national income is tourism.
That really is one of
the top still growing
exports in the country.
So that is a great
way to be helpful.
Thank you so much.